♪ Послухайте, люди добрі, що буду казати,
що буду казати... ♪
♪ Я буду про Ісуса Христа, співанку співати,
співанку співати. ♪
Заходьте.
Волинь — це одна з територій,
де лірницька традиція збереглась найдовше.
Мене це зацікавило давно, ще в дев'яностих.
Я знав, що в Києві є люди,
які займаються кобзарством, лірництвом.
Але я грав на етнічних духових,
а до лірництва руки не доходили.
В 2010 році я почув записи Івана Власюка
і мене цілком захопила ця музика.
Це була традиція незрячих людей.
У них були свої школи, свої цехи, свої правила, своя мова.
На певному етапі ця традиція змушена була
не перерватися, але видозмінитися.
Тобто ми уже не є такими послідовниками,
як ті незрячі лірники й кобзарі.
Ми, ті, хто цим займається, — свого роду реконструктори.
Реконструктори, які займаються продовженням цього,
передачею інформації і ми розповідаємо
людям про те, що лірництво було.
Граємо, виконуємо твори.
[грає на лірі]
Оцю ліру можна назвати традиційною.
Вона більш автентична, більш древня, хоч і недавно зроблена.
Тому що це є копія ліри, останнього лірника Івана Власюка.
Її зробив мені майстер з Луцька Віктор Іщук.
Тобто волинський майстер зробив волинську ліру.
Так вона виглядає: тут є колесо, є три струни,
одна струна – співаниця, і є два бурдона.
На струни намотується вовна,
або якась ватка, найкраще все ж вовна.
Змащується колесо каніфоллю — і от вам звук!
[грає на лірі]
От так звучить ця ліра.
Ось можете побачити,
ця ліра більш вдосконалена.
Це робота майстра з Польщі.
Її зробив Станіслав Нагай.
Вона має більше можливостей:
тут можна перемикати тональності.
Ця ліра, можна сказати, гібрид між українською
і мадярською лірою.
Майстер звісно добавив тут різні сучасні речі:
наприклад, є «собачка» яка ритм видобуває.
Поляки її називають «тромпетова» струна
[грає на лірі]
Ця ліра до мене значно пізніше потрапила.
Я її купив, щоб можна було...
Крім того, що я досліджую традицію, пробую,
що ще можна з цим інструментом зробити,
що на ньому можна грати, які звуки видобувати.
А ця ліра, вона в такому форматі —
дослідження лірницької традиції.
[грає на лірі]
Бував я і в Німеччині, і в Швейцарії.
Вони слухають.
Але коли не розуміють слів, про що лірник співає,
то їм цікаво, проте не довго.
[грає на лірі]
Я був на фестивалі «Оповідачі» в Любліні.
Італієць був з гармошкою, багато хто з різними інструментами зі сходу.
Я от був з лірою.
Під час виступу за музикантами на екрані
йшли титри, щоб було зрозуміло мову.
Тільки я і поляк виступали,
грали і розповідали без титрів.
♪ Ой зачекай же ти топір,
я нашлю на тебе камінь. ♪
♪ А камінь не йде топір тупить.
Топір не йде дуба рубить. ♪
♪ Дуб не йде ведмедя бить.
Ведмідь не йде хлопців драть. ♪
♪ Хлопці не йдуть вовка драть.
Вовк не йде козу їсти. ♪
♪ Козі горя немає!
І коза дома не сидить! ♪
Хоч в поляків своєї традиції не було,
але вони зараз ретельно вивчають [лірництво].
Але приходять до того, що всі польські лірники
були за походженням українцями.
Вони з повагою відносились і розуміли.
У всі часи лірників запрошували.
У поляків був звичай, що на весілля мав прийти лірник —
тоді у сім'ї все буде добре.
Коли відбувалось десь свято,
наприклад храмове свято в селі чи містечку —
то туди сходилось багато лірників.
І от в 1939 році в місті Лукові на Волині
хтось зафіксував, що на свято прийшло 15 лірників.
Уявляєте як їх багато було.
Вони ж не приїхали поїздом чи автобусом,
вони прийшли пішки з поводирем на це свято.
Це означає, що їм не дуже так далеко треба було йти.
Лірники – це ж не були жебраки.
Це скоріш були волхви.
Він розуміє, що якщо тебе не зрозуміли в селі, не заплатили,
дивляться на тебе дивно – значить туди вже не треба йти.
Треба повертатися тим шляхом.
Звичайно, у тих лірницьких цехах було
таке, що їм там маршути роздавали.
Мовляв, якщо один лірник йшов певним маршрутом,
щоб через два дні інший лірник не пішов слідом.
Бо там уже той пройшов.
Зараз намагаюсь досліджувати це питання ширше.
Що співали карпатські лірники?
Якби я заспівав їхні пісні на Волині – мене не зрозуміли б.
Там співається: «А ви люди, християни, грозіть свої діти.
Ви будете на тім світі, у пеклі горіти»
Що таке «грозіть свої діти»?
Для гуцула зрозуміло, що «повчайте, щоб діти гарно поводилися».
Так само на Волині теж є багато таких слів,
яких не зрозуміють південніше Збаража.
У цьому полягають [відмінності].
Також характерні мелодії Волині і Полісся, які там побутують.
Але вони уже незрозумілі для подолян.
[волинською говіркою]
♪ Отець Жалізо, з келії вийшов, сльозами й умліває: ♪
♪ Ой ратуй, ратуй Матір Божая, монастир загибає. ♪
Наприклад...
Якби щось із Дмитра Генцара,
останнього карпатського лірника, я грав, то там би було:
Там, по-перше, ліра по-іншому налаштована.
Я вже підлаштував:
[грає на лірі]
Там, наприклад...
[гуцульською говіркою]
♪ Ой гроби сі повтворєют, почєта всім буде. ♪
♪ Шо за житє заробили, то кожному буде. ♪
Відчуваєте різницю?
Що співали карпатські лірники,
а що співали волинські.
Майже всі інструменти я доводив до звучання.
Як є конструктори, які створюють літаки,
а є ті, хто потім випробовує, — літає.
То я от так часто ці інструменти, коли вони
від майстра до мене потрапляють, обігрую.
І вже доводжу до того стану, щоб вони грали.
Певну кількість псалмів і кантів чи якихось лірницьких пісень,
які співав вчитель, він мав передати своєму учню.
Учень ходив приблизно до трьох років за ним.
Це теж був незрячий якийсь хлопчик,
чи старший уже хтось, кого віддавали в науку.
Він ходив, слухав, вивчав.
Але дуже цікаво, що вчитель передавав учню не всі свої псалми,
для того, щоб це було не повне копіювання.
А щоб учень як творча одиниця
мав перейняти ще від когось псалми.
І щоб це була його власна інтерпретація
і щоб це не було на 100% копіювання свого майстра.
Це не може бути масовим, що всі візьмуть і
будуть грати на лірах і так ми будемо відроджувати.
Це завжди було традицією елітарною.
Не багато хто на грав на лірі і, мабуть,
це не потрібно, щоб це було масово
і всі цим захоплювались.
♪ Христос Господь воскресе.
Смерть для смерті принесе. ♪
♪ А нам животом новим.
Смерті вічний ізбавив. ♪
♪ Киріє, киріє, киріє елейсон.
Алилуя ♪